[Music]
you know what I think is something we
could all do without guilty pleasures
that's what I'm saying
I'm not saying you should stop Maldon
not that you should another you should
stop watching like reality TV if you
like reality TV
I'm saying you should stop feeling
guilty for enjoying reality TV why is it
a guilty pleasure if something gives you
pleasure its pleasure why are we all
apologizing like I like smashmouth sorry
I say if you love smash mouth love smash
mouth blasted from here convertible with
the roof down then drive to rehearsal
because if you love smash mouth you're
probably the lead singer of smash true
so let's stop having guilty pleasures
but listen I understand sometimes I'm
embarrassed by mine by my guilty
pleasures like recently I was watching
one of those vh1 kind of fluffy
countdown shows you know like I love all
the decades top 100 90s of the 80s
hosted by Carmen Electra you know I mean
it's fun it's just a bunch of comedians
with colourful backdrops telling me why
1984 was incredible just like he-man was
dumb man it's a fun time it almost
hypnotizes you what's not to love but
then my friend who was hanging out with
me he walked into the room and I reacted
like he caught me jerkin it exudes in
here
I jerk off like Gollum not on the card I
what I say that I should have been proud
I like vh1 countdown shows and jerkiness
sometimes at the same time it's hosted
by Carmen Electra that's what they want
guilty pleasures are just pleasures
don't bring guilt into this guilt save
guilt for other times like explaining to
an Ikea salesperson you didn't know that
was a non-functioning toilet they should
they should lock the door
you can't sell meatballs on one floor
I'm not see this coming
we deal with food too though people
apologize about food that they like like
Oh girls I am so evil ah someone slapped
me in the nose I am getting the deep
fried avocado egg rolls oh I hope they
come on the side of handcuffs cuz
[Music]
shut it stop it I'm not gonna judge you
for liking avocado egg rolls I'm gonna
judge you for not liking avocado egg
rolls in fact if you took a bite of one
and we're like yeah no I would love you
and that's what I'm saying stand behind
things you like
crank that Chumbawamba watch four
seasons of The Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills on a lonely Sunday eat the
Baconator maybe on the same lonely
Sunday and I say do it all guilt-free
somebody scoffs helix Oh Peter that is
trash for your eyes ears and your mouth
take a pause swallow the bacon pause the
bickering housewives like their husbands
wish they could turn up the chumbawamba
and tell him I get knocked down but I
get up again they're never gonna keep me
down
[Applause]
[Music]